hello and welcome to this video playing
em western em western yeah let's see me
you should be somethin I don't know I
mix my lights down yeah a4 yeah this is
getting really popular I really didn't
understand what's so great about it but
it keeps it keeps getting played okay
well if i just take it let's let's play
it very simple here they usually let T
and let why take on a seven but I wasn't
really sure the games that I've watched
that is really a big issue okay so
likely before comes so let's try to make
that a little bit more difficult to
achieve okay
I would absolutely like to regroup that
be aight night somewhere well not
somewhere i have an idea where to see
five but i'm not sure that i get this in
this looks wrong a little bit but maybe
if i get to e 695 i can probably just
take this is not a big issue i hope yeah
that looks very fancy I admit that and
fancy often means bad 92 c4 is coming
okay so
if you take then go through p5 sister
this is the thing really really a
problem I came here I never do this now
maybe he takes with the night actually
pawn takes Knight c5 I thought is still
quite resilient I mean I don't like my
position don't get me wrong but I felt
that this still could be quite quite um
holdable him out maybe he just wants to
take okay let's try for some counter
play me
I know f3 is not the greatest come to
play ever I'm yo cam
maybe this would be one would be a door
something probably sure I've gone to g5
I don't really know why I went back to
e7 that makes crumbs Chuck makes little
sense actually
yeah it's not great what can I do
it takes you five I might have Queen f6
here threatening 97 I don't know if
that's really a friend maybe
maybe yes no it doesn't have ruby three
see more maybe maybe has rook see one or
something like that so 95 Queen f6
doesn't really work I can maybe ready i
can just take you for 95 94 takes pawn
takes jack it's a bad position but is it
losing not sure at least his King looks
somewhat vulnerable as well
okay so it's no direct culture check I
don't know I still think taking gives me
some flame it takes it seven but
probably the king of this is probably
save enough okay here i can actually try
to do something on the beef file maybe
and this one it takes twice as rupee to
maybe just looks your bone and save this
yeah maybe time morning
hmm so how would you do it
you want to try to sacrifice on age
three and I don't see how I can set that
up okay d7 24 actually should be okay so
loop d3 is the idea now not so easy to
defend against tubes cannot stop both
that's crazy amazing very nice play now
ah very nice am very nice is that when
you're winning for white probably does
this is winning I have no doubt there
would I felt like yeah amazing I quindi
three wins very nice yeah I mean it was
a it was a bad position I really got
into a bad position here this yam chap
maybe I still have to keep this I wasn't
sure about this taking and Group B 5 how
bad that really is and then I decided to
take and this was really the thing i
don't know i mean probably with
hindsight it wasn't a great idea the
alternative is to play this and go I'm
sorry go for f5 but okay
clear that he does that and here I
wasn't sure at all but the computer now
shows that f5 was possible here and
probably gives enough power to play I
didn't see that I can actually give that
pawn immunity I'm getting getting
material back down but not so not so
quickly engine still thinks is equal
which is a bit surprising now maybe
maybe I'm just okay it's possible engine
gives equal yeah and here I'm probably
into some trouble no matter this this
doesn't help this is back and forth
business and here i can just fish for us
some kind of yeah some kind of tricks
but it didn't didn't work out he played
that really nicely at the end okay
thanks for watching